hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space - okay we just got
off the elevator doom from an idiot
what
oh hey baby
[Music]
she's kind of crushing my neck right now
why would he help me in this situation
- sweets acceptance
[Music]
Oh five stages of grief
I get that's weird but I still don't
trust you lady
seriously you can't stay away from me
you were kind of choking me so that's uh
dad no yeah advanced suit let's see Oh
used up all of my forget all of my
plasma energy all of my line racks just
gone hello stasis recharge time decrease
by 50% 50% holy crap
yes please and 25 in now I get out of
this ugly suit
all right looking fancy again whoo I
like that color scheme better than the
other one
oh yeah look at yourself oh yeah oh you
so handsome
[Music]
yeah awesome
okay I think that's the last suit that
you need so I need advice serious plasma
like serious plasma all right and the
rest since I don't need to buy any more
suits I can spend on power notes and to
add power goes I got chance
yeah Adam you okay ah here's the bench
Thank You mr. been shot all right well
is it going up
last weekend
says the target on fire one shot that's
probably pretty handy
think that's what I need upgrade them
flavor
what matters if I'm gonna keep using
really
see all fur
just increase the damage of the all-fire
sweetener
oh yeah someone mentioned um I need to
pull the power notes from my javelin
that I think if I'm not gonna be using
the javelin hey I should definitely get
the power notes of them I need to get
some of these anyway and then let me
toss in the Flint or just for a second
oh I gotta take a second bear with me
I said bear with a dot dot don't sass me
sass I heard that
respect
five thousand credits to get oh I don't
have any power nose in there wait no I
didn't i have great something
didn't I didn't I was the other guy
couldn't have been the rivet gun no way
that piece of [ __ ]
no weight at all so apparently if I
didn't have any in there and the only
the gun in I have in there it's a really
gun so all right bring on the flavor I
thought I put some in there apparently
not what
so now
let's see you here I kinda want to get
stasis just to get these charges up in
that way it means like with the advance
suit like my card like amazing cool
all right now liquor fast beat
I get to the damage well I could but I
don't want it now go through that way
it's all the same right
okay all right that'll do a little more
damage ins capacity reload one-line
rankling BAM
back off I got a suit chapter 12 is
chapter 12 the last chapter diner acts I
see you okay
oh hey mechanics tractor rig nothing
service le sorry about that okay I
wasn't either so what happens now I
wasn't you just trust to destroy the
Mokka
trust could lead us to the marker he was
running away from his guilt yeah
what about you I'm not running anymore I
know what I have to do
yeah baby I know well this drills a
stroke a good luck finally why don't you
get it to the cab you try to get it
started I'll look for the other power
cell
see what I can do from up here okay baby
excuse me while I watch you climb
totally not creepy you so nimble what
done don't okay do it alright okay let
me know if you need anything she's gonna
be all safe up there and I'm gonna be
down what what what did they just kill
themselves oh I see
[Music]
that's not what I wanted
yeah good right
all dead yeah this is where the power
why is it like right next you know I
guess I'm not complaining and rather not
have to run around everywhere trying to
fetch still whatever now my fault what
standard there should be another one
around here somewhere hey don't fast me
Oh pressure I'm under
oh yeah is there any other suit besides
this one if there's a super ultra mega
elite suit poink oh hello baby hi all
you have holographic controls I saw them
oh I don't know let's trust out this
stasis
oh shut up
yeah I don't know how long it takes to
recharge hasn't done it yet so I'm upset
[Music]
hi I'm like
oh hello no all my stasis recharge no
grab your puke out of the sky vivid help
and gone I'm going what how many things
do I gotta shoot off you don't learn
obey my commands
ah more what I didn't hear its nerd love
angry engineering
no little months is why I got the waiver
bird
Bern Bern yes
nope
mark
whoa hello
hello bye
cut off goodbye
essentially give a lot of good
restocking I love pork
good
nope
I wish
oh they just keep coming but I guess
that's a good thing considering how much
they're giving me
okay thank you oh we're moving oh okay
we're scum
Wow right ahead
that way
I'm a fighter
yep what
dammit dammit what thank me
seriously what's hitting me
what was hitting me
why can't I be cannot can I climb in the
cab there seems to be room could it
could I please sorry I'm in your way
hello shut up
I know
I'm kind of here aware of the situation
oh hello Barrett
wrong questions to ask at this
inopportune time
I shot you
BAM
Oh
there Wow you are there
they're not really a danger to me if I
said God
oh okay it's okay baby I understand I do
what you gotta do
Wow
that up no cases that right in your
gullet and you
yes
I don't miss except like all the time
I guess none of these are blacks not
really a big deal man
all can't hit what you can't see
Goody's ah where do you come from
in it
[ __ ] off
Oh detonators what am i doing
I know don't kill me bro
what [ __ ] ah I kept hitting the cue
button but like I got no health I didn't
I had medium Hillary wasn't it using
this might be a long episode on how long
okay at least it's not sending me back
to the beginning
like what the [ __ ] does hit me
seriously you sons
family
my god
you need more hits
god
one shot [ __ ] no
you know how are you right
come here give it I do all these this
I'm not gonna plan
I really don't know what killed me last
time because I have 20
and then I just like your exploding
la Rana
I can't you can't he'll handle all this
real-time construction
[Music]
okay we almost there yeah
whoa whoa whoa stop stop stop lady looks
like rigid foundation piles of the
government sector so how do we get in
there
straight ahead you do have a giant drill
you know I'm right now top of this thing
right
it was only for Elly's I read five okay
hello hello hi Isaac
didn't look like it well compare or is
it later
or at least we made it right and this is
most definitely government sector mm-hmm
and I'm guessing that bar of yours is
behind that huge door over there
oh good guess you could just jump down
plate yeah you've been thrown into space
you but dragged through a mine you've
got tossed through a wall I think you
could handle a little bit oh there's a
chapter 13 okay
gah safety all right that's all the time
I got for this episode thank you guys so
much for watching and as always see you
in the next part
bye bye